[Music]
and we continue with team coverage
bianca holman stopped by woodlawn
cemetery that's right near downtown las
vegas earlier on today
for its annual memorial day program
yes here at the cemetery there is a flag
at each site
for soldiers who died serving their
country remembering those who left to
fight for freedom
but did not return home making the
ultimate sacrifice
feelings of gratitude and love but also
a time
to mourn the memorial day program
honored heroes who gave their all
for their fellow comrades and country
it's been two years since the program
was held in person so there were many
families
veterans and active duty personnel here
we spoke with an army reservist who
named his son after a peer who died in
combat
he dedicates this day to him it wasn't
for nothing
we honor you every day matthew matt
morris
i love you and i would give my life for
yours
all of us together need to say today is
the beginning of my
giving back to this country and being
purposeful in what i do
and being accepting and making sure i am
a positive force
in this city in this county in this
state and in this nation
it's also a time to recognize gold star
families children
spouses and parents of those who lost
their lives
during service and we're all asked to
take a moment to pause
to remember our military personnel who
died during their service
bianca holman 8 news now